este es un autorretrato que hizo
rembrandt en 1640 y lo interesante de
esto es que como muchos grandes artistas
como leonardo da vinci y salvador dalí y
muchos otros más
a rembrandt le gustaba mucho usar algo
llamado la proporción dorada en khan
academy hemos hecho varios vídeos sobre
esta proporción que es algo realmente
fascinante normalmente se denota como
fin si es igual a 1.61 803 y continúa y
tiene unas propiedades matemáticas
geniales si comenzamos con 1 y le
agregamos 1 en 3 y nos da si esto está
genial si multiplicamos ambos lados de
la ecuación por fin nos va a quedar sin
más 1 igual a fi al cuadrado el cuadrado
de si es firmas 1 también podemos
expresarlo como fin igual a 1 + 1 entre
1 + 1 entre 1 +
así infinitamente y no sólo es genial
matemáticamente también lo encontramos
en el mundo natural y es muy usado por
los artistas porque piensan que les
ayuda a definir la belleza humana
podemos ver que rembrandt de la usaba en
sus pinturas como no sabemos eso vamos a
analizar esta pintura aquí construimos
un triángulo este no es parte de la
pintura original simplemente lo
agregamos la base del triángulo está
donde reposan sus brazos y los dos lados
del triángulo enmarcan sus brazos y
hombros y se unen en lo alto de este
arco así tenemos el triángulo a vd y si
pasamos a los ojos que es algo que
naturalmente buscamos cuando vemos un
rostro o al retrato de un rostro humano
si dibujamos una línea horizontal que
conecta los ojos y sea paralela a la
base esta línea será el segmento pr la
proporción ante el triángulo pequeño a
pr y el triángulo grande abed va a
involucrar a fin
la proporción dorada eso es lo que
sabemos la proporción del segmento se ve
con respecto a veces es decir a uno este
segmento de acá el cde
es fin si la proporción de este segmento
bc es un ahora el segmento pr es
paralelo al segmento bebé que decir que
estas dos líneas son paralelas
segmento hace tiene la proporción con
respecto al segmento aquí decía uno con
respecto a uno esto nos indica que
rembrandt de verdad uso esta proporción
la altura del triángulo más alto a hace
su proporción con respecto a la altura
del triángulo más pequeño aquí es firmas
uno a uno o sima zona ahora usamos toda
esta información para explorar más al
respecto y encontrar una expresión que
indique la proporción del área del
triángulo ave con respecto a la del
triángulo a ver este triángulo de acá
quiero a ver si podemos hacerlo en
términos de fin con alguna constante o
algo así
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y lo
traten de hacer por su cuenta
hagámoslo paso a paso cuál es el área
del triángulo un medio por la base por
la altura por lo que el área del
triángulo abed es igual a un medio por
el segmento bebé o la longitud de ese
segmento por la longitud del segmento ac
y cuál es el área del triángulo a perry
aquí abajo
al hacer un medio de la longitud del
segmento pr por la longitud del segmento
aquí como podemos simplificar esto pues
vamos a quitar este un medio entre un
medio pero que más sabemos nos dan la
proporción de hace con respecto a q que
es si massú no vamos a reescribir todo
esto como que es igual a bb entre pr por
fui más 1 entre 1 cuál es la proporción
dvd con respecto a pr la relación de la
base del triángulo grande con respecto a
la base del triángulo pequeño pensemos
un poco en ello pues vemos que ambos
triángulos son similares
es obvio que ambos triángulos tienen el
ángulo a este de aquí en común y como pr
es paralelo a bb sabemos que este ángulo
b corresponde al ángulo pe y de este
otro lado
el ángulo de va a corresponder al ángulo
r por lo que tenemos tres ángulos
correspondientes congruentes así que son
dos triángulos similares luego
de los triángulos similares es que la
proporción entre las longitudes de las
partes correspondientes de hecho van a
ser iguales y nos han dado una de dichas
proporciones nos dieron la proporción de
la altura del triángulo grande hace con
respecto a q que es igual a fi más 1 con
respecto a 1 si esto es cierto para una
parte de los triángulos similares
entonces se cumple para todas las partes
correspondientes así que la razón o
proporción de la base del triángulo
grande con respecto a la base del
triángulo pequeño también será fi más 1
entre 1 esto de cada bebé entre pr lo
sustituyó por fi más 1 entre 1 y esto lo
simplificamos como fi más uno al
cuadrado y esto se merece un redoble de
tambores aquí los invito a que
reflexionen sobre esto ya que sabemos
que fi más uno es igual a fi cuadrado y
hay otras muchas formas interesantes de
seguir analizando esto